[Music]
the house voting unanimously to
declassify all intelligence related to
origins of covid-19 but President Biden
he's not on board
sign the bill to declassify the covet
intelligence hey
Mr President
wandering over
so why is the White House reluctant to
release the facts Florida congresswoman
Kat hammock joins us now congresswoman
thanks for being here why the reluctance
you don't see unanimous overwhelming
votes like this yet he hesitates why
listen I think that the writing is on
the wall from the Biden Administration
when you have Republicans and Democrats
unanimously voting to declassify these
Intel reports that's pretty telling and
when you think about his reasons for
dragging his feet maybe it has to do
with the fact that it really would force
them to act they would have to take
action on China they would have to take
action on all of the funding sources for
The Who for NF uh NIH CDC FDA it would
open Pandora's Box and really expose the
deep-rooted collusion between the Biden
Administration and all of the social
media companies that had to work
overtime to cover up all of the
dissenting opinions on the issue of
covid this really is the worst thing
that could happen for the Biden
administration because it flies in the
face of the narrative that they've been
pushing for years and I would say follow
the money yeah absolutely follow the
money and I've just been I'm kind of
enjoying this moment there's so much
being revealed from you know the lies
about January 6 so the lies about the
origins of covet the lies about the
efficacy of the vaccine is that the
solution is that really the Panacea for
this you know totalitarianism that we're
seeing in America right now where
they're trying to force us to believe
things we know weren't true so many
people were called racist
um for for saying that China you know
that it came out of that China lab what
do you make of all these lies being
revealed and good on the Republicans by
the way for taking the charge on that
absolutely you know I have a colleague
who she says repeatedly that sunlight is
the best disinfectant and I think you
talk to Americans today regardless of
their party affiliation Republican
Democrat independent they have a
deep-rooted mistrust of their government
they're highly skeptical of the mandates
they're skeptical of really anything
coming out of this Administration and so
to restore that trust to restore
accountability to really get to that
transparency that Americans deserve we
need to open up Pandora's Box we need to
get to the bottom of so many of these
issues from the hunter Biden laptop
story to election Integrity issues of
course the origins of covid is a massive
massive issue that branches off into
like I said the big Tech covering up for
them this is something that if we don't
get to the bottom of I think Americans
will rightfully say you know what we
just can't trust what's coming out of
our government and that has serious
implications not just here at home but
abroad as well so we have a shot to get
it right in this 118 Congress
Republicans are very very aggressive and
we're working in a way that is so
diligent so cut and dry that there is no
room for error that even Democrats on on
some of these committees are saying you
know what it's time to come to the table
it's time to get something done for
America it's time to put country before
party let's hope when they release it
it's not so heavily redacted that you
see nothing from it which is something
they could attempt to do as well let's
turn real quick if we could
congresswoman to Hanoi Jane Fonda who's
back in the news for all the wrong
reasons yet again she was on The View
yesterday and said this about pro-life
politicians maybe like you watch
and protesting what else do you suggest
well it doesn't happen overnight it's
not a miraculous what did you say murder
wait a second she's just I don't say
that you don't know they'll pick up on
that again she's just kidding it's well
let me talk to you about that
congresswoman this is personal for you
yeah absolutely I I mean I think one is
clear that the view has become a
platform for hate you know remember
Whoopi Goldberg has made more
anti-semitic remarks than than I can
remember uh Sunny just last year called
women considering voting Republican
cockroaches and now are we shocked that
Hanoi Jane is on there talking about
murdering politicians friendly reminder
Title 18 of U.S code that's a crime and
it's not funny where's the outrage
where's the cancel culture that's right
it is none because it doesn't fit their
narratives that's right it doesn't she
claim to apologize that it was a joke uh
yeah we'll see about that uh
congresswoman Kat kamik great to see you
as always appreciate it have a great
weekend I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis